oh
[Musique]
oui
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous allons évoquer la
question des réfugiés en jordanie syrien
en majorité sachant que cette petite
monarchie le deuxième pays du monde qui
accueille le plus de réfugiés réfugiés
donc syrien en l'occurrence et pour en
parler j'accueille aujourd'hui francesco
baert qui est responsable des relations
extérieures du haut commissariat des
nations unies pour les réfugiés
merci francesco berthe d'avoir accepté
notre invitation bonjour merci alors
vous nous parlez à dahmane en jordanie
aujourd'hui et vous vous préoccupez
particulièrement du sort des réfugiés
syriens qui ont fui la guerre qui ont
fui des villes quasiment totalement
détruite comme alep et homs alors
dites-nous déjà pour commencer au niveau
des chiffres combien y at-il de réfugiés
en jordanie
combien dans les camps combien ailleurs
et combien de syriens
d'accord d'accord
écoutez je rallie au jour d'aujourd'hui
il ya plus ou moins 750 mille réfugiés
enregistrés auprès du hcr
d'ascète chiffres là la grande gt c'est
à dire les
7% sida vg syrien et donc on vous
l'avait dit c'est qu'ils ont fait ici en
jordanie en tant qu êtres chers et avec
les autres états unis bien sûr c'est
surtout de laisser occuper de ces
réfugiés syriens et là jusqu'au moment
où les réfugiés décide de rentrer dans
leur pays d'origine donc là on est en
2022 donc on en vient d'entrer dans la
11e année de la paix civile
c'est quelque chose d étonnant quand
même si vous voulez les chiffres par
rapport à la population totale ainsi
avant la guerre la moitié disons six
millions de places en plus ou mois et
aujourd'hui déplacé soit amateur du pays
inscrits soit à l'extérieur dans les
pays voisins notamment le liban la
turquie et la jordanie dont je vous
parle aujourd'hui comme vous le disais
la jordanie c'est un pays qui a que deux
réfugiés les accueille depuis longtemps
gds important aussi d
des noter que je veux n'y a que des
réfugiés depuis longtemps et même avant
naka syrien il affiche un palestinien
depuis
1948 et il y avait des réfugiés il ya
qu'elle a portée de la guerre du golfe
dans les années 90 aussi au début des
années 2000 est là justement dans les
derniers des années s'est écrié a pris
l'ampleur c'est justement la crise des
fusées ciel comme je le disais l'un des
réfugiés sur les sites depuis longtemps
et ils sont pour la plupart les 85% et
vit en fait dans les villes de jordanie
commun ici ou alors ma femme qui habite
plutôt d'un énorme il y a effectivement
deux camps de réfugiés les a trahis et
azou at il dit s'être plutôt au nord du
pays donc près de la frontière à
tayac est aujourd'hui plus ou moins
quatre amis qui travaillent même façon
et à vraies qualités sont donc cent
vingt mille personnes et 120 mille
réfugiés vit aujourd'hui dans des cas
c'est à dire que c'est quand même une
minorité si on regarde la population
réfugiée jean et il s'agit plutôt de
réfugié si vous voulez plus vous venez à
sela est possible dans l'essence qui est
dans les cada sujet les services sociaux
de base sont rapides donc tout ce qui
est à part la santé à une question est
aussi le logement c'est gratuit donc
fait c'est la chair à partir de fonds
parmi les donateurs la qualité
attentionnel qui s'occupe des réfugiés
là c'est une question assez des femmes
pour réfugiés qui vit aux bouquins et
donc cela doive payer quand vous pouvez
imaginer des loyers est aussi delanoë
tour et tous les respects et la jordanie
est un pays très cher en plus avec un
audioguide vivement oui donc ça en fait
on regarde toujours et par rapport à vos
neurones it et donc on faire
chaque année on va voir un peu les
chiffres des volets réalité parmi les
réfugiés et si vous voulez avant la
crise du coup vite de la pandémie déjà
les 80% des réfugiés vivent et gare au
dessus de la seule épreuve était donc
imaginez vous comment ces gens là
peuvent aller les jours et sans avoir
des possibilités économiques réels donc
c'est que en tant qu'égérie faits ont
contribué avec des transferts d'espèces
cet ancien moniteur aussi pour les
réfugiés qui vivent du cac évidemment on
peut pas assister tout le monde ça
saignait sont disponibles mais quand
même chaque mois au lieu de trente mille
personnes une personne n'a plus ni
famille au fait les soirs un petit
mouton un argent qui leur est même comme
une fois dé payer pour le service des
basses
c'est là n'est pas sa vision il est
clair donc c'était assez différente qui
est cher c'est d'insister un peu sur les
possibilités économiques comment est ce
qu'il a fait je peux en fait s'il prend
soin de chez eux tout en pouvant
travailler c'est qui est important ici
des appelé c'est qu'il est juste rien
est encore jeune et scénic 5 mon permis
aux réfugiés des travailler tous que
tout ce que vous me citer celle là ça
laisse entendre que la jordanie c'est
finalement très bien organisés pour
l'accueil des réfugiés ce que c'est un
pays modèle parce qu'il ya carrément un
plan très organisé très bien doté pour
l'accueil des réfugiés
oui je dirais que comme je le disais
c'est ça fait partie de l'histoire un
pays la jordanie est un pays qui était
toujours au milieu d
ela donc disons que les pays les
autorités locales ont pu apprendre des
ces crises passées et là tout de suite
si vous voulez apartheid a fait syriens
les l'organisation était là donc les cas
de réfugiés on est établie au début de
la crise a failli année en 2000 tous
hélas qu'un il a justement
je veux des réfugiés qui était toujours
en train de devenir de la série en
allant vers le deuxième camp des racques
2014 évidemment même vacances n'était
pas suffisant et c'est à ce moment là
que les réfugiés ont commencé à
s'éparpiller si vous voulez un peu dans
les pays mais encore une fois je disais
que si le gouvernement est
favorable si vous voulez un lacet les
chantiers ouverts il n'y a pas mis aussi
aux réfugiés de pouvoir venir et 105 oui
ce qui n'est pas une attitude que quand
tous les pays alors comment ça se passe
pour les budgets que par exemple combien
de l'union européenne comment la france
est engagée aussi puisque sommes
français comment ça se passe
les goûters un tas cacher nous on est
évidemment on travaille par rapport aux
contributions volontaires des
gouvernements et des peuples donc là ça
dépend évidemment des notre capacité d
alors que via le fonds nécessaires si
vous voulez l'année passée par exemple
2021 notre budget était autour de 4,5
millions de dollars on aurait su plus ou
moins les 60% des responsables qu'est ce
que ça veut dire comment comment on peut
travailler là dans ce contexte là il
faut évidemment faire des priorisations
donc il faut briser certaines activités
au lieu des autres et qu'on voit est
celle qui est effectivement il faut de
notre côté assuré c'est les services de
protection dont le service à production
égale la possibilité de réfugiés dr
comtois avoir accès à une rupture avoir
accès à la santé à l'éducation c'est là
évidemment un coût important en jusqu'à
là je veux dire c'est c'est vrai que ma
pub etc c'est merci aux donateurs soit
donnée européens et la france aussi en
contre lui façon importante et c'est
important de le dire parce que là depuis
dix ans d'arrêt syriens on voit quand
même comme il ya des autres is a démangé
afghanistan par exemple mais il y en ad
autres les yémen simple ici dans la
région et donc évidemment les montants
d'argent disponible elle n'est toujours
pas suffisant mais quand même on a pu
faire pas mal d'activités je voudrais
aujourd'hui à quoi nous a permis de
travailler d'une façon assez ouvert ce
qui n'est pas des cas dans d autres
contextes donc juste il est important de
trouver d'un dans son contexte où le
gouvernement quand même et oui vous
soutiendrez vous accompagner alors pas
par exemple c'est vrai que là avec les
deux camps dont on parlait et ce sont de
véritables petites villes avec de très
nombreux services est ce que vous pouvez
nous nous parler de cette vie au
quotidien parce qu'il ya des maternités
il ya des écoles racontez nous un peu la
vie quotidienne des camps
écoutez oui moi je la choisis des 17
pays
ouest
des voix et je veux dire qui est encore
une fois la jordanie c'est un peu la
mode est dire c'est qu'un de réfugiés
donc des fois en 1 impression vous voyez
des tentes autour d'un désert alors ça
c'est pas le cas ici et
vous voilà il ya des carabins plus tôt
et donc si vous voulez c'est des maisons
dur qui sort c'est qui déjà permis une
vie beaucoup plus digne et permis aussi
aux réfugiés voyez ici un jour ni même
il fait chaud c'est c'est un pays ouvert
aux éléments et même pendant des mois
d'hiver récemment on vient justement
terminé en quelque sorte les mois
d'hiver où il faisait foi il faisait
très froid il a même neigé ce qui est un
peu exceptionnel pour les pays et dans
ce cadre qu'ont fois il y à une
organisation qui qui nous a permis
nethaera de situations où vous voulez
des tentes ou lot de maisons il y alors
qu'ils rentrent dans et donc il y à des
services sociaux de base d'un clic sol
qui permet une vie quotidien digne
réfugiés donc c'est ce qui est important
et quand vous le disais dans les corps
il ya plusieurs structures qui permet à
refuser de se soigner il ya plusieurs
hôpitaux il ya des cliniques spécifiques
il ya des cliniques de maternelle il y a
aussi des écoles il ya des costumes
ainsi qu'au secondaire donc
effectivement c'est ils ressentent le
tour de ville si vous pensez et 90
personnes c'est quand même des moyens en
france en europe et là donc il
s'agissait ce tout à fait les hr joue
l'erreur de musicalité si vous voulez
donc entendait s'assurer que ses
services sont disponibles pour tout le
monde et qui en a besoin et aussi ce qui
est encore une fois j'ajoute les points
les réfugiés aussi ont la possibilité de
travailler
avec des entreprises soit chez eux soit
en développement est donc là encore ils
ont la possibilité de gagner un argent
dit sionnel qui leur permet de
s'éloigner
en effet parce qu'ils ont ils peuvent
bénéficier de permis de travail mais ce
qu'est ce que beaucoup de personnes en
bénéficient justement est-ce qu'ils ont
la possibilité réelle parce que c'est
une chose différente d'avoir un permis
de travail mais il faut également
trouver du travail
c'est vrai et écouter les fait que les
réfugiés peuvent accéder au marché
reste c'est quelque chose il faudrait
connaître il faut beaucoup d'efforts par
rapport aux rassemblements pour planète
ça dans un contexte où je rappelle ici à
giovanni on a plus ou moins les 25% du
taux de chômage donc vous comprenez bien
que permettre aux réfugiés
décidé de travailler sauve tout de suite
la possibilité à
certaines questions par rapport est ce
qu'il est réfugié ils sont en train de
voler les travaux des des jordaniens
alors oui c'est une 6ème place
d'ailleurs dans tous les pays avec avec
les réfugiés c'est la question la
population à une certaine partie de la
population craint que les réfugiés entre
en concurrence avec leur travail oui
alors là encore une fois on est dans
l'association où effectivement les
discours si vous les xénophobies ou
alors la crainte dont vous parlez et ne
s'est pas manifesté ici c'est à dire les
jordaniens sont toujours qu'il ya chaque
chaque fois
même des sondages en fait chaque les
sinois et là encore on a remarqué que
les 92 % des gens manière sont toujours
accueillante alors est-ce que ça ça va
mais c'était comme ça est ce qu on peut
simplement s'asseoir quelques villes et
un peu plus de crise économique à cause
du coc vie donc le regard peut changer
mais c'est vrai que ces notables à 92%
de jordaniens favorable c'est
exceptionnel et quand vous le disais la
scène actuelle et les effets du co vise
donc les économique les deux dernières
années en fait on nous emmener dans une
situation où les problèmes que les gens
gagnent en font face aujourd'hui c'est
sûr que les mêmes que les réfugiés font
face dont fois trouver des opportunités
de travail d'être de travail décent et
trouver des possibilités pour qu'on va
avoir une éducation
au délà de l'ecoop merci condé vous
voyez donc tout ça et c'est d'aider des
défis qui avoir assez avec nous pour ce
passionné et il a un confort c'est lié
au fait que réfugiés et niveau peuvent
être tout de suite dans leur pays donc
ils vont essayer ici enfin quelques
années et bien sûr on parlera c'est que
en effet c'est ils sont parfois là où de
manière durable ils vont pas tous se
retourner en syrie faisant jusqu'à part
je vous interromps nous allons marquer
une courte pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
de retour avec francesco berthe porte
parole du haut commissariat des nations
unies pour les réfugiés qui nous parle
depuis amman en jordanie alors francesco
fait on parlait peu de temps avant de la
possibilité de se former et donc ce sont
des initiatives qui ont été mises en
place dans les camps est ce que vous
pouvez nous en parler au delà de l'école
bien sûr
si vous voulez la possibilité pourrait
refuser de travailler c'est quelque
chose d qui a commencé en 2016 c'est
qu'on appelle les doors d'un compact
hommes s'étaient inquiétés sort un
événement qui est établi un tout la
jordanie le gouvernement jordanien et le
numéro terrain et là évidemment c'était
donner l'opportunité si vous voulez aux
réfugiés de travailler mais aussi donner
notre actualité au ter me de travail
développé et en même temps les échanges
permet aussi aux produits jordanien d
accéder au marché européen avec avec un
tour des moins chers si vous voulez donc
cette zone c'est une possibilité aussi
des communiqués à la jordanie et en tant
que yara réfugiés en tant que plus grand
de réfugiés et leur visibilité ça y est
c'est là va voir bénéfices sur
l'économie jordanienne
au lhc ou est ce que en 2022 on peut
tirer un bilan là dessus je pense que
c'est encore un peu trop tous les faire
on peut certainement diack et le nombre
de réfugiés qui ont pu accéder un marché
de travail a été importante justement en
2021 d'années passées mais il ya le
raccord des soixante deux mille permis
travail qu'il était employé aux réfugiés
c'est là est très important mais un
confort à la conjoncture économique
c'est quelque chose que l'on peut par
bus alors pour les enfants combien de
français scolarisés dans les camps
alors écoutez là on peut être très fier
si ce qui me fait si vous voulez les
cinq ans pour sondés 48% et des réfugiés
syriens dans les pays aux moins de 18
ans donc
vous comprenez tout de suite que toute
cette population des enfants
ont la possibilité et s'ils voulaient
voir dans les décors comment il s'agit
et comment il sait comment ça s'est
passé concrètement et il y a en fait de
tous si vous voulez la matin dans la
matinée il ya des filles qui vont les
corps et dans l'après-midi sur les
garçons donc qu'on voit comme je le
disais dans les camps il ya les écoles
des écoles établi il ya donc en fait si
vous voulez c'est les 5% des enfants qui
ont ensuite été donnée à l'école et
qu'ils ont fait ils y vont 1 je voudrais
dire que pendant les deux dernières
années et ça c'est justement parce que
je n'y mets plus tôt dans le monde
entier si vous voulez il y a bien eu
toute l'histoire des lockdown et c'est
ce qui a contribué à si vous voulez les
l'éducation virtuel là on a vu aussi que
sa mue en effet d'un réfugié ici ce
n'était pas facile
la connexion internet ce n'est pas
quelque chose de donner surtout dans les
quinze se vidant les ans donc on a de
nous faire des interventions là encore
doit améliorer la situation générale et
pays pour pouvoir donner accès internet
et permettre des cours
d'école de continuer ça n'a pas été
facile justement encore aujourd'hui avec
la situation
du coup vite il y a encore des écoles
qui ne finissions par personne je pense
exactement aux jeunes et des systèmes de
bourses ou des formations particulières
même des des jeunes réfugiés qui peuvent
être envoyés dans des systèmes d'études
à l'étranger comment ça fonctionne qui
donne dans ces cas là alors qu'on voit
là c'est ça dépend des planteurs il y
annonce d'études il ya des possibilités
et pourtant ces possibilités sont
limitées si vous voulez il ya un
programme qui s'appelle d'affi qui est
opposé par le gouvernement allemand est
où
qui permet si vous voulez à travers de
booster tout en certains réfugiés il y
en a une cinquantaine l'année passée de
accéder à des universités ici à schoten
évidemment les universités en janvier
celle ci un coût additionnel et ça coûte
cher et donc ces bourses s et limiter
ses possibilités sont pas limités à
métaux il ya certains réfugiés qui est
vraiment je vous parle d'une petite
minorité qui ont la possibilité soit
avait des contacts personnels soit à
travers des moyens financiers
exceptionnels d'accéder à des bourses
d'études à l'étranger mais là encore on
peut pas parler de quelque chose qui est
accessible à tout le monde est ce que
vous êtes confronté également à la
baisse des donations à cause de la crise
du code vide
parce qu'écouter en fait en 2020 et je
devrai d'un souvent mesure en 2021 est
en fait la crise du que vite a généré si
vous voulez des donations additionnel
donc les gens effectivement par rapport
à cette situation et devient quelque
sorte le général les gouvernements aussi
les gouvernements aussi et je veux dire
certains gouvernements en particulier à
je pense aux états unis est belle mais
aussi vidéo pea et la banque mondiale si
vous voulez donc cette nation en 2020 et
2021 nous ont permis de mettre en place
et reconditionnés je parlais tout à
l'heure des transferts d'un chante alors
normalement les trams une famille qui
assoient l'argent par rapport aux
services sociaux de base on a pu y
assister vingt mille additionnel et ça
c'était justement pendant 2020 2021
alors l'âme 2022 ce qu'il est clair que
ces fonds additionnels dont a bénéficié
dans les deux dernières années ils vont
ils vont pas être là et c'est parti les
cannois cher tout récemment les
premièrement les guerres mondiales
partenaire on dû faire face à un convoi
blé d'éruptions dans leurs fonds
disponibles et c'est là tout à fait un
effet cascade sur les problèmes que nous
remettre donc c'est toute l'organisation
si vous voulez que c'est bien simple ne
s'est pas souvent de cacher ses réseaux
pendant tunis et les ong qui était
jusqu'à tout récemment msf médecins sans
frontières a fermé ses poulains dans les
cales des centrales pas que ça pour ma
défense dans voyez bien que si on
continue
avec cette habitation
oui la situation va devenir de plus en
plus compliqué faute faute de budget on
entend bien alors pour parler du coc
vite quand même également il ya eu une
campagne de vaccination la jordanie
était le premier pays à vacciner les
réfugiés vous pouvez nous en parler
oui et écouter des depuis le début de la
prise en fait ils étaient 1 mars 2010
si vous vous rappelez et les rois
il est il est sorti en télé en disant
carrément toute façon qui se trouve ici
et jordanie a les doigts d'être soignés
et donc nous on va pas différencier
entre jean ganiayre et nogent gagner et
il a des dents il ay l'agrément marqué
des réfugiés à temps qu'est ce qu'on
voit dans cet esprit des limites et des
pouvoir accéder à programmation
intéressante ou huit ans il ya tout
avant la campagne de vaccination même
donc d'abord il ya toute une sorte de
traque et qui était mis en place par
rapport à mettre en place des sites et
des quinze-vingts dans les camps de
réfugiés savez vous imaginez il ya
beaucoup de gens donc ce n'était pas
facile on a mis en place dès des
hôpitaux dédié à la console ou vie donc
cliniques spécifiques pour répondre pour
l'aca qui effectivement nous a permis de
ne pas avoir autant de cas quand il
habitait limiter la mortalité due qu'aux
vis des autres fai mentalité était
limité et même le nom de cannes n'était
pas de départ et là si vous voyez de la
moyenne nationale et est donc là en 2021
en janvier donc ça fait plus de plus ou
moins un an de là et c'était le début de
la campagne de vaccination alors qu'on
fait la jordanie a pu accéder de façon à
trouver les gouvernements si vous voulez
à au vaccin est là les réfugiés ont pu
accéder aux salles de vaccination donc
les réfugiés je parle au dehors de cas
et de façon gratuite et côtoie les
réfugiés dans les camps ont pu
bénéficier des dessins de vaccination
installés directement la dépense donc
celle qui nous a permis un confort de
vacciner au jour d'aujourd'hui que de 80
à 90% des refuges et
d'élodie sud et digitales sont vaccinés
ce qui est carrément d'accord et je
pense que ça c'est ce n'était pas
seulement les faits d'avoir le versant
disponible mais c'était 7,7
particularité cette inclusion dans les
gouvernements dans les plans du
gouvernement et aussi les capable de
sensibilisation qu'on a mené avec nos
partenaires et tân dung pendant toute
l'année s'il ya eu carrément d'existence
on a vu un peu par tout le monde et il
ya vue d'aider plusieurs personnes qui
voulaient pas ses maximes et est
pourtant là qui à petit on a pu mener
une campagne efficace
un maximum de réfugiés et pour parler du
retour des réfugiés syriens plusieurs
dizaines de milliers sont retournés en
syrie dont une partie qui s'était
installé en jordanie provisoirement est
ce qu'un système d'accompagnement parce
que j'imagine que tous ces réfugiés
n'ont pas et un habitat ou un travail
qui les attend comment ça se passe dans
ce cas là
écoutez les retours de réfugiés ainsi
évidemment cesse c'est simple c'est
quelque chose de très compliqué
compliqué parce que ça devienne tout de
suite aux questions politiques alors
jusqu'à là les hrt claire et les choix
des retours doivent être en syrie c'est
ça doit être un choix de réfugiés dans
cette map un choix volontaire
et par rapport à figer il faut pas que
il y a quelqu'un qui pour se réfugier en
crise
c'est parce que je sais que c'est vous
être le cas
écouter jusqu'à là le gouvernement
jordanien n'a pas n'a pas laissé les
réfugiés enrichissent et il faut encore
dit ça c'est très différent si on
regarde ce qui se passe au liban ou
alors même un pour qui ces jours là et
pourquoi je pense que le refuge est ici
en jordanie la plupart des refuges et
vient du sud de la syrie donc la zone
d'aller damas et les suites de masse et
tous ces gens tous et tous ces hommes
est aujourd'hui dans ces zones là si
nécessaire
c'est effectivement il ya des situations
très particulier de la sécurité n'est
pas complètement atteint et ça c'est
rare fois les réfugiés qui part avec les
gens qui sont rentrés quand vous le
disais il ya des gens je dis manqué sur
l'attrait des coûts 2018 en californie a
réouvert la fraude qu'elle est on on a
calculé plus ou moins caramilk à 140 et
amis qui sont entrés de façon volontaire
en série l'année passée il y en a eu
plus ou moins si un corset et ours et
des retours organise les façon spontanée
les achètent pas la peau a cessé ses
tours un confort parce qu'il achève mais
tout papier l'est la situation si vous
voulez dans les pays d'origine et propre
si vous voulez pour les retours de
réfugiés en même temps nos collègues a
civilisé c'est d'avoir accès à ces zones
de retour ce n'est pas tout à fait le
cas surtout dans les studios nasri n'est
pas facile il ya toujours des combats
toujours demeure donc ce n'est pas
quelque chose facile pour analyser mais
en tant que ça si un réfugié disant nous
approche ici même dans les autres
centres la cites doit cher et nous
demandent qu'est-ce que je peux faire
nous le donne d'informations comme
indisponible mais un confort le rappel
écoutez nous on n'est pas en mesure de
vous de vous accompagner une fois que
vous êtes rentre ainsi donc si vous
voulez en fait c'est votre choix et si
vous voulez faire vous allé défaire il
faut aussi rappeler tous les six mois un
confort en fait des sondages est en
demande de réfugié qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire quel est votre intention
par rapport aux 3,6 et il est
intéressant de voir quelle majorité des
réfugiés ils se disent
il veut rentrer il veut autre chose et
c'est tout à fait normal mais quand la
question est ce que vous êtes prêts à en
faire d'ici les prochains 12 mois et de
la dépression la promotion celle inverse
ou 4,90 5,10 nom n'est pas n'est pas
prêt dans les prochains 12 mois parce
que on reconnaît que la solution s'il
n'est pas là pour nous permettre d après
ce n'est pas seulement question
politique c'est aussi une question
d'avoir des possibilités d'accéder à des
moyens de subsistance dans les zones de
retour si vous rentrez chez vous et
votre maison détruite si notre chez vous
et il n'y a pas de possibilité de
travailler évidemment il n'y a pas
beaucoup de réfugiés qui n'ont faire ce
choix donc ça dépend encore une fois des
situations je n'ai dans les villes
d'origine dans des zones de richie qui
tout va qui pourra changer cette
dimension là c'était pour l'instant de
réfugiés là donc je vais te réfugier le
bon rester ici en jordanie
c'est exactement ça pour un an au moins
encore à moyen terme c'est la fin de
cette émission francesco berthe merci
beaucoup de nous avoir parlé de la
situation des réfugiés syriens je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole du
haut commissariat des nations unies pour
les réfugiés vous nous parliez d'amman
en jordanie merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission vous pouvez la retrouver en
replay sur rt france point tv merci de
votre fidélité à bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]